la menace de la maladie du coronavirus
plane désormais au tour de la maison
blanche le président lui-même aurait été
en contact direct avec des élus
républicains place et ensuite en
quarantaine la porte parole du président
affirme que donald trump n'a pas été
testé positif
le chef de l'état américain qui doit de
nouveau s'exprimer sur la pandémie
mondiale ce soir hier il a annoncé
subitement l'arrêt des liaisons
aériennes avec l'europe provoquant la
colère des responsables européens
l'europe nouvel épicentre du coronavirus
dans le monde selon l'organisation
mondiale de la santé
la pandémie a fait plus de 5000 morts
sur la planète tous les pays renforcent
leurs mesures pour éviter une
propagation trop rapide
les rassemblements de plus de 100
personnes sont désormais interdits en
tanzanie se fait par le premier ministre
aujourd'hui
lire on appelle le fmi à led plus de
onze mille malades et plus de 500 morts
à ce jour dans ce pays le plus touché
après l'italie le fonds monétaire
international avaient promis début mars
d'utiliser des financements d'urgence
pour aider les pays membres à faire face
aux difficultés économiques causés par
l'épidémie mondiale du courant d'un
virus les forces de sécurité de la
république islamique ont reçu l'ordre de
vider les rues
[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue sur rt france à la une
de l'actualité ce soir l'allocution de
donald trump depuis la maison blanche le
président américain qui va de nouveau
s'exprimer dans quelques minutes sur la
con délit mondial lui qui a longtemps
cherché à minimiser les risques dus
coronavirus a annoncé mercredi
l'interdiction de l'entrée des européens
aux états unis et cela pour les 30
prochains jours
il a pointé du doigt notamment le rôle
de l'europe dans cette crise sanitaire
la primaire démocrate qui devait se
tenir en louisiane le 4 avril a été
reporté au 20 juin prochain la gestion
du coronavirus qui devient donc un enjeu
électoral pour la présidentielle de
novembre
l'organisation mondiale de la santé qui
a déclaré l'europe nouvel épicentre de
la pandémie mondiale du coronavirus
aujourd'hui avec davantage de personnes
infectées et de morts que l'ensemble du
reste de la planète excepté la chine
bien sûr c'est maintenant le vieux
continent qui enregistre le plus de cas
chaque jour avant-hier l' oms avait
alerté sur des niveaux de propagation
alarmant et avait dénoncé notamment
l'inaction des gouvernements pour lutter
contre la maladie
écoutez du rop has now be comme
maintenance grotte est devenu
l'épicentre de la pandémie à leur
contamination kate moss dans le reste du
n 6 et la chine enregistre plus de cas
chaque en europe d'un camp chine au bol
fort de l'épidémie est en france nouveau
bilan donné par le ministre de la santé
olivier ferrand ce soir lors de son
point presse quotidien
79 morts et 800 cas de contamination de
plus qui hier écouter le monde la france
font face
à une menace sanitaire inédite que
l'organisation mondiale de la santé
qualifie désormais de pandémie et dont
elle estime que l'épicentre est
désormais l'europe
cette menace s'étend dans 118 pays ce
soir elle progresse partout elles
progressent également sur notre
territoire national nous comptons ce
jour 3661 malades soit près de 800 de
plus qu'hier alors à laquelle je vous
parle
soixante dix neuf personnes sont
décédées 154 malade se trouve toujours
dans un état grave notamment dans les
services de réanimation
ces données nous montrent que l'épidémie
je vous le disais est installé en france
et plus largement en europe
ces données nous montrent également que
malgré les mesures que nous prenons
l'épidémie progresse c'était attendu et
pour tenter de prendre des mesures afin
de ralentir la propagation de l'épidémie
la france a interdit tout rassemblement
de plus de 100 personnes à partir
d'aujourd'hui annonce faite par le
premier ministre français à la mi
journée
écoutez nous devons interdire les
rassemblements de plus de 100 personnes
afin de freiner la propagation du corona
virus cette interdiction s'appliquera
sur tout le territoire national et dès
maintenant notre objectif principal est
de préserver la santé des français et de
retarder le pic épidémique au maximum
même s'il y aura des conséquences
importantes pour les théâtres ou encore
les cinémas edouard philippe qui a
également évoqué l'organisation du
premier tour des élections municipales
qui seront bien maintenu comme l'a
confirmé hier emmanuel macron voter
c'est sans danger c'est pas plus
dangereux que d'aller faire ses courses
a affirmé le chef du gouvernement
il incite les plus fragiles a opté pour
des procurations encore possible selon
lui en ce qui concerne les
établissements scolaires les crèches et
les universités ils resteront fermés
aussi longtemps que nécessaire
probablement jusqu'aux vacances de
pâques est il précisé edouard philippe
qui
exclu en revanche de fermer les
frontières à l'instar de certains pays
comme le réclame notamment une partie de
l'opposition
une interdiction de rassemblement de
plus de 100 personnes qui ne
s'appliquerait pas pour les
manifestations précision faite par le
ministre de l'intérieur christophe
castaner il a tout de même invité les
organisateurs à les reporter
systématiquement pour éviter toute
propagation
écoutez les mobilisations et les
rassemblements dans la rue ne sont pas
interdits car il ne faudrait pas laisser
penser qu au nom d'un motif sanitaire le
débat politique serait clos mais en même
temps j'invite chacun et chacune et les
préfets le feront systématiquement quand
il y aura des déclarations à reporter
ces mobilisations et nous avons demandé
justement à l'une des figures des gilets
jaunes qui je vous le rappelle sont dans
la rue tous les samedis maintenant ce
qu'il pensait de ses déclarations
voyez ce qu'on dit jérôme rodriguez
toujours en première ligne dans la lutte
pour le pouvoir d'achat
le souci aujourd'hui c'est que on nous
interdit des rassemblements à plus de
100 vous voyez les supporters du psg
pour se rassembler on nous interdit
d'être à 100 vous voyez les transports
en commun
être ouvert pour que les gens puissent
aller travailler les magasins sont
ouverts
donc la question un moment donné il est
très compliqué nous en tant que
manifestants de savoir ce qu'on doit
faire
je vous dis on surf entre l'information
et la désinformation donc concernant le
mouvement des gilet jaune je le répète
je ne suis pas décisionnaire je ne suis
pas un lider beaucoup de discussions
vont je pensais être mis en place dans
les différents deux groupes gilet jaune
qui est aujourd'hui son actif dans le
mouvement pour savoir quelles suites
seront à donner au mouvement par rapport
à la situation actuelle qu'on est en
train de vivre
voilà et c'est les informations vont
venir petit à petit c'est vrai que au
même titre que l'ensemble des ronces
d'informations qu'on peut avoir via les
médias la situation change de minute en
minute
donc à nous aussi nous adapter face à la
situation
l'état français qui a promis de prendre
à sa charge la totalité des frais
engendrés par le chômage partiel
la ministre du travail mme muriel
pénicaud a précisé les contours de ces
mesures à destination notamment des
travailleurs ou bien des parents
d'enfants de moins de 16 ans qui
seraient obligés de passer en
télétravail voyez les détails en images
[Musique]
non
pour la fermeture des écoles et des
crèches un casse tête pour certains
parents cela concerne également les
collèges les lycées ainsi que les
universités
mais le ministre de l'éducation a
prévenu ce ne sera pas des vacances pour
autant il va falloir travailler à
distance
écoutez michel jean michel blanquer
depuis maintenant plusieurs semaines
nous avons mis en place les mécanismes
continuité administrative et de
continuité pédagogique surtout puisque
notre but c'est évidemment que aucun
élève ne reste au bord du chemin dans
une période exceptionnelle comme celle
ci la france a des atouts en matière
d'enseignement à distance
elle a une institution qui s'appelle le
cned depuis fort longtemps qui est
préparé pour cela et depuis plusieurs
mois nous avons préparé cette
institution pour donner des cours à
distance en appui au travail que les
professeurs font ils le font souvent au
travers des environnements numériques de
travail qui existe plutôt dans les
collèges et des lycées et nous allons
donc avoir grâce au cned ce mécanisme
que nous appelons la classe à la maison
qui permet d'avoir à la fois et classes
virtuelles et des ressources
pédagogiques pour tous les enfants
les réactions de l'opposition à ces
mesures gouvernementales d'exceptionnel
via les réseaux sociaux regarder un des
premiers moyens de freiner l'épidémie
était évidemment d'effectuer un contrôle
aux frontières qu emmanuel macron se
refuse à faire pour des raisons
quasiment religieuse tout en disant
lui-même qu'il va peut-être être obligé
de le faire c'est une incohérence face à
la crise ducobu 19 la seule attitude
possible est celle de la responsabilité
collective
personne ne doit manquer ce soir le
président de la république a répondu
elle large part de nos demandes nous
accompagnerons l'effort et veilleront à
ce que les paroles se traduisent en
actes
l'union nationale oui mais avec des
actes concrets et efficaces
la situation est trop grave pour se
satisfaire de belles paroles et de demi
mesure il aura fallu une crise mondiale
pour que le président de la république
comprenne que le modèle d'un monde est
mort
et voyez à présent l'analyse de philippe
maurer économistes hilaire et un réagi
justement la pertinence de ces mesures
on nous résoudre à cette crise qui est
économique quand on aura résolu là
et sanitaires or on voit très bien qu'on
à 2800 cas aujourd'hui
si on continue ainsi dans un mois on
multiplie par dix toutes les semaines on
aura 28 millions de cas ça se passera
pas parce qu'on prendra les mesures et
donc on est en train de prendre un
risque absolument énorme avec la santé
des français
c'est absolument inconséquent
irresponsable monsieur macron prendre
des décisions extrêmement fait pour
arrêter la crise sanitaire qui est le
problème principal
avant la crise économique et donc
pourtant on a la leçon de l'italie qui a
fait les mêmes mesures que nous il ya
dix jours qui n'a pas du tout réussi à
arrêter l'épidémie les journalistes
français les politiques italiens
appellent notre gouvernement à être
réaliste il ne fait rien on ne comprend
pas ils responsables incompétents
cynique on peut se poser la question et
dans tous les hôpitaux de france le plan
blanc maximal a été déclenché tout acte
chirurgical non urgents sera reportée
pour libérer des lits et ainsi
accueillir un maximum de malades
voyez les précisions et la réaction de
gerald kerzec médecin urgentiste
l'idée c'est de ne pas arriver à la
situation italienne c'est à dire un
afflux de patients dans les hôpitaux et
donc pour cela il faut cantonné c'est ce
qu'on appelle les mesures de
distanciation sociale en mai les gens
les sommes loin des autres et en
particulier les enfants qui sont
porteurs probablement même réservoir de
ce virus et assistance publique hôpitaux
de paris maintient ses crèches ouvertes
donc on voit bien qu'elle est un peu à
géométrie variable
cette cette mesure de fermeture des
crèches ou des lieux ou des lieux de
garde
si on ferme les écoles pour faire
d'autres modes de garde qui met des gens
ensemble ça n'a pas de sens l'objectif
c'est de mettre des mesures de barrières
entre les gens et donc que les individus
ne soit pas ensemble c'est ça la
distanciation sociale si c'est pour
transposer une classe dans un dans une
salle de cours ou de je ne sais quoi du
conseil régional ça n'a aucun sens bien
sûr à l'idéal c'est le confinement à la
maison on voit bien que fermé des écoles
ça coûte pas grand chose les parents ça
va les embêter pour le mode de garde etc
mais économiquement c'est encore
supportable est acceptable ça aurait été
beaucoup plus compliqué avec des
transports par exemple là où il ya un
peu une ambiguïté dans une contradiction
c'est que quand on dit que les élections
municipales et 2
quote donc les personnes y compris les
personnes âgées vont se déplacer et
qu'on dit aux personnes de plus de 70
ans de ne pas se déplacer donc on voit
bien que là il ya une contradiction les
élections municipales c'est clair que
c'est un brassage de populations quand
vous avez 40 millions d'électeurs même
avec de l'abstention ça fera une bonne
vingtaine de millions qui vont se rendre
aux urnes
l abstention justement c'est la grande
inconnue pour ce scrutin local de
dimanche quelles sont les précautions à
prendre
la réponse en images regarder
[Musique]
à
m
[Musique]
des élections municipales maintenu donc
à deux jours du premier tour voyez la
déclaration d'alain gazeau il est maire
adjoint de châtillon et candidat udi
écouter ideye très pragmatique et va
voir des positions qui vont être d'abord
dans ces municipales dans l'intérêt de
la gestion d'une commune ce qui fait
qu'on peut être allié certains endroits
ça dépend des configurations locales
réaction également du maire les
républicains de maisons laffitte jacques
myard
vous avez des gens qui sont entrés dans
le territoire
ce sont les élus locaux de l air qui
savent gérer leur ville qu'ils sont
véritablement établie qui ont le sens du
bien public et qui ont le sens de la
détermination dans la durée et la
cohérence
le secteur du tourisme également
durement impactée face aux demandes de
remboursement en masse les voyagistes
français réclame un dispositif
exceptionnel
voyez les explications de cyrielle
benavides bullion panique à bord dans un
communiqué commun les entreprises du
voyage et le syndicat des entreprises de
tour opérating ont alerté le
gouvernement de leur situation
nos organisations sont confrontés à des
demandes massives de remboursement en
numéraire justifiée ou non
dans ce contexte de fortes tensions sur
la trésorerie des entreprises
de tels remboursements mettre en péril
les entreprises ces deux organisations
qui représentent la quasi totalité des
agences de voyages et des tours
opérateurs ont informé qu'une baisse de
25% de l'activité avait été enregistré
au mois de février avec une décroissance
accru la dernière semaine de 60%
sans compter les demandes massif de
remboursement de la part de leurs
clients
la loi exigeant un remboursement en
numéraire nous vous demandons de toute
urgence de prendre les mesures décret ou
autre permettant de proposer comme
alternative un bon d'achat ou un avoir
valable un an
l'industrie du tourisme emploient 35
mille salariés directement menacés de
pertes d'emplois et plus de 3000
entreprises menacées de disparaître
de ce fait le gouvernement a déjà
reconnu le secteur comme étant
prioritaire dans cet état d'urgence
économique des mesures drastiques
également prise par la belgique où l'on
a recensé trois décennies et aux copies
de 19 et 399 cas de contamination à la
belgique qui a fermé ses lieux publics
les écoles les cafés les restaurants les
discothèques seront fermés à partir de
cette nuit jusqu'au 3 avril tous les
rassemblements seront annulées également
annonce faite hier soir par la ministre
la première ministre belge des belges
qui sont plutôt partagés sur cette
mesure écouter pour nous c'est très dur
la décision qui a été prise
je n'en vois pas pour quelle raison le
gouvernement a pris une décision
drastique comme ça je pense que ça sera
compliqué mais voilà il faudra y faire
face aussi tout est fermé
forcément on va rester à la maison après
c'est vrai qu'il y aura forcément des
voilà des conséquences ou
des difficultés mais voilà il faudra les
surmonter l'italie elle a passé le cap
des 1000 morts pour plus de 15 mille cas
à contaminer les rues sont désertes
comme vous allez le voir ici à rome
notamment ou encore à venise où la place
saint marc a été vidée de ses touristes
même scène à milan 60 millions
d'italiens qui doivent rester confinés
chez eux dans le nord du pays
tous les commerces et que c'était les
enseignes alimentaires et les pharmacies
sont fermées
vous voyez le témoignage du journaliste
et écrivain olivier goujon il vit en
lombardie
on peut sortir il s'agit de sortir avec
une ce qu'on appelle une auto
certification c'est à dire que on
certifie on promet consorts pour un bon
motif
donc on peut sortir pour faire des
courses mais l'essentiel parce que
depuis passons les magasins sont fermés
on peut sortir pour raisons de santé
c'est à dire se rendre à des
consultations par exemple ou pour des
raisons urgentes
on peut également 6 6 pour une bonne
raison encore une fois voyager les bars
les discothèques les restaurants tout
est fermé les magasins un peu plus lourd
plus faire de shopping donc ya pas
vraiment non plus de raison de sortir en
sorte pour l'essentiel certaines
pharmacies ont mis en place à un système
de guichet avec des files d'attentes
les supermarchés sont ouverts également
de manière un petit peu fractionné ont
fait la queue dehors en respectant un
distance d'un mètre ou d'un mètre
cinquante
et puis à l'intérieur d'un voilà on fait
rentrer les gens 5 par 5 10 par 10 20
par ben ça dépend de la taille d'un des
magasins globalement l'italie réagit
très bien les gens sont solidaires ils
sont responsables et assume globalement
un comportement très digne une crise
sanitaire qui bousculent également très
fortement les marchés boursiers la
bourse de paris a enregistré un léger
rebond en fin de matinée avant de
replonger en début d'après midi
même chose à londres à milan ou encore à
francfort le cac ne gagne 15
lui pour cent après un jeudi noir hier
où il a chuté de plus de 12%
wall street qui termine sur un plongeon
de 10% c'est sa plus lourde chute depuis
le krach boursier d'octobre 87 un crack
qui ne semble pas à remonter pour
soulager les banques la bce va injecter
120 milliards d'euros supplémentaires
sur les marchés
pas question d'abaisser son taux déjà
très bas de 0 5%
voyez à présent l'analyse de pierre
bentata il était l'invité hier de notre
émission c'est cash avec olivier
delamarche pour les deux économistes la
chute des cours de la bourse pourrait
bien traduire une dépendance des marchés
au politique monétaire de la bce
écoutez coincé pour coincer et on vit
sous perfusion de toute façon si vous
coupez la perf du jour au lendemain
c'est c'est fini donc ils sont coincés
mais le problème avec ça c'est que si on
reste dans cette logique
en fait ce qu'il nous faut c'est
exactement ce qui a toujours été fait et
ce qui est la cause profonde de la crise
et de nous dire il va falloir soutenir
la demande parce que c'est une crise de
demandes et on va inciter les gens à
s'endetter mais le coeur du problème
c'est la dette c'est convient aux dons a
vécu au dessus de nos moyens parce que
l'argent il faut et en fait mal ce qui
se passe sur les places financières
est ce que récupère les entreprises n'a
aucun rapport avec les fondamentaux réel
donc mécaniquement on comprend qu'ils
aient une attitude c'est peut-être même
un bon signe c'est que les marchés se
disent bon ben c'est pas la bonne
solution c'est c'est pas ça qu'il faut
faire vous pouvez pas nous refaire une
forme de quantitative easing ou la
réinjection à la veuve de monnaies parce
que finalement c'est vous vous êtes
juste en train de créer une bulle alors
soit c'est pris comme ça et c'est bon
signe soit l'avenir nous dit qu'en fait
c'est qu'on attend encore plus et c'est
très mauvais signe ça veut dire qu'on a
des en fait des entreprises zombies que
comme on a au japon qui ne vivent que
grâce à de la dette et qui attendent
plus de dettes parce qu'il voit qu'avec
ce niveau-là ça suffira pas et là là
c'est très mauvais signe coach croit
aujourd'hui que les marchés attendent
réellement le signal que la banque
centrale est toute puissante et il
semble alors on pourrait dire en voyant
la baisse des cours que le marché a
compris qu'en fait la banque centrale a
perdu la main
mais je j'ai peur quand même que ce soit
l'un la deuxième opposition c'est à dire
que le marché disent mais en face c'est
inadmissible elle n'a pas baissé les
taux en même temps et c'est alors qu'on
s'attendait à des mesures encore plus
fortes
on s'attendait en gros à ce que madame
lagarde disent à écouter s'il faut 1000
milliards pour remonter bien on mettra
1000 milliards s'il en faut 5 milles on
en mettra cinq mille c'est ça qu'ils
attendraient pas le cacher ce qui n'est
pas le cas mais vous inquiétez pas ça va
venir c'est à dire que dans les semaines
à venir si on continue sur ce rythme là
il est évident que vous allez avoir une
action concertée des banques centrales
qui vont vous dire écoutez voilà on est
là nos limites comme l'avait dit draghi
nos limites
s'il faut cinq mille milliards on mettra
cinq mille milliards s'il en faut dix
mille on en mettra dix mille à la
commission européenne qui réagit
également à travers sa présidente ursula
von der leyen
elle a recommandé davantage de
flexibilité notamment dans les règles
budgétaires pour les états membres de
l'union européenne
écouter des choses pires ils doivent
être encouragés à prendre toutes les
mesures nécessaires pour soutenir les
gens s'opposent people for exemple par
exemple via des programmes de travail à
temps partiel ou d'autres mesures
efficaces faute pour cela c'est à dire
pour rassurer les choses nous au niveau
européen allons offrir une flexibilité
maximale cimente l'accident l'été est
selon pierre emmanuel comme alger au
politologue et fondateur du site heureux
continent la difficulté se cache
notamment derrière les divergences de
décision des états européens
la difficulté en réalité c'est les
approches différentes que les états
membres les idéologies derrière les
décisions des états membres parce que
les états membres ont des conceptions
différentes du projet européen
on voit bien que certains pays ont
décidé de fermer les frontières par
exemple pour ralentir la propagation du
virus alors que par exemple
la france et l'allemagne ont mis plus de
temps à prendre des mesures drastiques
on voit qu'il ya des différences de
modèle le modèle européen jusqu'à
présent son paradigme c'était la société
ouverte la démocratie libérale
l'ouverture le moins de frontières
possible et la priorité aux échanges et
à l'économie et on voit que c'est que
ces paradigmes ses fondements du projet
européen sont remis en cause et pour
l'instant l'afrique reste le continent
le moins touché par le coronavirus dans
le monde une centaine de cas ont été
recensés jusqu'à présent pour le moment
13 pays sur 54 ont annoncé des cas de
coronavirus et au moins cinq décès parmi
les pays les plus touchés figurent la
république démocratique du congo
l'afrique du sud la côte d'ivoire ou
encore le maroc sur son réseau social le
président de la république du sénégal où
l'on recense une dizaine de cas a appelé
à une réponse africaine coordonnées
conséquences économiques de ce
coronavirus la chine pourrait réduire
ses investissements en afrique notamment
voyez les explications de samuel mater
il est économiste et président fondateur
de la fondation africaine pour
l'entrepreneuriat et le développement
économique pour les que la chine a une
sommet chine afrique qui a été un sommet
pour à définir les axes d'investissement
de la chine vers l'afrique et que la
chine aujourd'hui a également une base
dans la corne de l'afrique
donc quand tous ces éléments sont remis
en cause et également au niveau du
secteur privé qui sera difficile à
quantifier parce que l'investissement de
la chine vers l'afrique et à deux
niveaux et au niveau du public c'est à
dire ce que veut le gouvernement chinois
investis à l'afrique directement et au
niveau des privés au niveau des privés
mais les montants ne sont pas
véritablement déterminé mais peut être
aussi énorme que le montant de
l'investissement public chinois à
l'afrique
et vous vous rendez compte que
personnellement aujourd'hui pour ne pas
faire de la publicité
j'ai une voiture dans les pièces
détachées sont fabriqués en chine et à
une semaine je suis tombé en panne
quand je suis parti chez le
concessionnaire on m'a dit c'est dans
six mois à cause du cours d'un virus
situation toujours très critique en iran
les forces de sécurité iraniennes ont
reçu l'ordre de vider les rues dans les
24 heures à venir l'iran qui est l'un
des pays les plus touchés par cette
propagation derrière l'italie plus de
dix mille cas de contamination et 5 114
décès selon un dernier bilan
pour éviter à un désastre économique
téhéran a appelé le fonds monétaire
internationale à l'aide
et là medjahed c'est la première fois
depuis près de 60 ans qu l'iran demande
l'aide urgente du fonds monétaire
international une demande faite par
courrier vendredi dernier mais annoncé
ce jeudi 28
la directrice générale du fmi a déclaré
que les pays affectés par l'épidémie de
kobe de 19 serait soutenu par
l'intermédiaire de l'instrument de
financement rapide
notre banque centrale a demandé un accès
immédiat cette facilité le conseil
d'administration du fmi doit rester
fidèle au mandat du fonds être du bon
côté de l'histoire et agir de façon
responsable
téhéran veut obtenir du fmi à près de 5
milliards de dollars pour lutter contre
le coronavirus particulièrement virulent
dans le pays
mais il ya peu de chances que
l'organisation monétaire répondent
positivement à la demande iranienne
problème aucune décision ne peut être
prise par le fonds monétaire
international sans l'aval de washington
et on sait les états unis mènent
actuellement une politique de pression
maximale contre téhéran dans le dossier
du nucléaire
le président américain cherche à
assécher les finances de la république
islamique et rien ne montre jusque là
une volonté de donald trump de
l'infléchir conséquence téhéran ne peut
plus utiliser ses propres fonds bloqués
dans les banques internationales
d'ailleurs dans une autre lettre
adressée au secrétaire général des
nations unies le chef de la diplomatie
iranienne a demandé la levée immédiate
de toutes les sanctions américaines
contre l'iran
l'un des principaux foyers du couronne
un virus dans le monde ces derniers
jours les autorités du pays ont
multiplié les mesures drastiques pour
contrôler l'épidémie
les iraniens sont invités à rester chez
eux et éviter de voyager à travers tout
le territoire
dans le reste de l'actualité la
libération hier soir de la lanceuse
dallaire chelsea manning l'ancien
informaticien trice de wikileaks avait
refusé de dénoncer son fondateur julian
assange
l'ancien analyste également du
renseignement de l'armée américaine a
tenté de mettre fin à ses jours mercredi
depuis sa prison d'alexandria en
virginie
elle avait été transférée à l'hôpital
depuis
retour en images sur le parcours
pénitencier de chelsea manning
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et voyez là la réaction de stéphanie
gibeau à cette libération de chelsea
manning est les lanceuses d' alerte et
auteur de l'ouvragé la traque des
lanceurs d'alerté aux éditions max milo
c'est une question finalement de rapport
de force voyez vous c'est à dire que les
pressions sont telles qu'il faut arriver
à des extrémités pour pouvoir avoir ses
propres droits appliquée on peut faire
un parallèle aussi avec la situation en
europe de dieu la naissance que vous ne
pouvez pas ignorer inquiète lui aussi
enfermé depuis presque une année dans
cette prison à londres on peut aussi
faire le parallèle avec roues et pinto
ce lanceur d'alert des footballs x dont
plusieurs gouvernements ont bénéficié de
ces informations
le moral elle avec un brin snob même qui
est en quête en asile comme vous le
savez depuis 2013 c'est à dire que ces
grands lanceurs alerte ce sont des gens
qui n'ont accepté aucune compromission
et on peut tous leur tirer notre chapeau
parce qu'en fait en étant droits dans
leurs bottes
c'est à dire en acceptant en aucun cas
d'être compromis il montre que justement
leur détermination paye à terme une
conférence interne et viennent de
réconciliation prévue cet été en
ethiopie décision prise par le groupe de
contact de l'union africaine réunie hier
au congo l'objectif est de faire cesser
les violations de la résolution
onusienne qui porte notamment sur
l'embargo des armes à tripoli mais
également sur l'ingérence des puissances
étrangères dans ce conflit libyen
écoutez à la une de l'actualité ce soir
l'allocution du président américain
donald trump qui doit s'exprimer des
jardins de la maison blanche donald
trump qui vient d'arriver
conférence de presse du président
américain sur le coronavirus après sa
première allocution qui a surpris tous
les européens et qui avait décidé
d'interdire tous les vols en provenance
et vers l'europe
vous les voyez est ce que dit ce soir
donald trump sur le coronavirus nous
avons fait beaucoup de si l'on compare
ce que nous avons fait à d'autres
régions du monde
c'est assez incroyable cela a beaucoup à
voir avec la désignation rapide et la
fermeture des frontières et savait
l'europe a été désigné comme le hotspot
est une coronavirus et nous avons fermé
la frontière il a déjà quelques temps
que ce soit du talent de la chance
c'était très bonne chose quand ces
actions collectives le sacrifice à notre
détermination qui surmonteront cette
menace gmc mercredi soir suite à l'avis
de nos professionnels de la santé qui se
font du très bon travail et nous en
sommes reconnaissants que hugh suspens
dont l'un très l'entrée des
ressortissants européens pour au moins
30 jours
ils ne pensent qu télé trait aux états
unis les citoyens américains et leurs
familles qui rentrent d'europe subiront
un dépistage et un auto complètement sur
40 jours
l' oms a confirmé aujourd'hui que
beaucoup de nos affirmations était 100%
vrai notamment notre désignation avant
eux de l'europe en tant que faux lieu
très forte vis-à-vis de la chine ont
sauvé un nombre incalculable de vies
beaucoup de personnes que vous voyez
derrière moi on dit que cela sauvé
beaucoup de vies notre action nous
entrons dans la phase avec le trajet
très anciennes très contraignantes
elle existe depuis longtemps elles ont
été mises en place entre que je vous en
débarrasser a été efficace
il s'agit d'utiliser tous les pouvoirs
tout à fait dira je déclare donc l'état
d'urgence nationale
ce sont des 50 milliards de dollars
seront disponibles c'est très important
cela représente beaucoup d'argent pour
le gta le territoire les localités g20
d'élite et contre tous les états de
mettre en place des centres d'opération
et je travaille à côté de beaucoup de
personnes officiellement le sentier
j'étais en place un plan de préparation
médicale afin de pouvoir répondre aux
besoins des habitants par tout autre
endroit ont déjà commencé
j'ai parlé avec les personnes concernées
nous avons eu des conversations intimes
et nous travaillons avec beaucoup
d'états dont l'état des connaissances
copie du décret pour être appliquées
afin de stocker tous les besoins de
toute la souplesse dont ils ont besoin
pour répondre aux faits juste aux
autorités de santé cela concerne les
autorités que j'ai évoquées notamment un
nouveau système si incroyable qui est
arrivé assez récemment télé s c'est
vraiment génial c'est la ceinture à
distance jeu cela permet au docteur de
faire des visites et des consultations à
distance éviter certaines certaines
conditions pour les licences médical
ainsi être appliquée bien plus
efficacement
on peut sexy de plus les conditions que
oui nombre des lits d'hôpitaux
conditions d'hospitalisation
cela concerne cela concerne également la
possibilité de réquisitionner de haut
niveau personnel de santé
ils peuvent faire ce qu'ils ont besoin
de faire ils savent ce qu'ils doivent
faire
maintenant ils pourront le faire sans
[Musique]
supprimer les règles qui conditionne jeu
m'accueille de la science un les
hôpitaux afin que
ces mesures d'urgence soient rapidement
mobilisés nous supprimons tous les
obstacles afin de fournir à notre table
les soins dont ils ont besoin et qu'ils
méritent
l'économiste buzz au fur et à mesure
nous ferons tout saupoudré fois évoquée
je sais parler avec les pdg des
laboratoires pharmaceutiques afin qu'ils
renforcent les tests en circulation les
autres pays coopèrent avec nous à
stocker même mesure où ils s'appliquent
nous annoncent aujourd'hui un
partenariat avec le secteur privé afin
de renforcer et d'accélérer notre
capacité à dépister le virus
nous voulons faire en sorte que ceux qui
en ont besoin puissent bénéficier de ces
tests rapidement et facilement et en
toute sécurité
ben oui nous ne voulons pas que des gens
soient testés alors qu'ils n'ont pas
besoin
ce n'est qu'avec l'apparition de
certains symptômes qu'on peut être
contestées l'agent de la nourriture et à
trouver le gîte est ce processus le il y
aura bientôt plus dans l'eau et est la
semaine prochaine et cela commencera
sans douche dimanche soir je souhaite
remercier rush cette grande entreprise
pour ce travail et je souhaite commencer
également tous les autres afficheurs
la fda a autorisé cette application en
l'espace de 24 heures s'il avait très
très rapide cela représentera 1,5
million de tests supplémentaires d'ici à
la semaine prochaine et 5 millions de m2
là je doute que nous serons encore
besoin
il ya également des négociations en
cours avec les revendeurs et le fermer
et afin que des tests soient disponibles
sur place objectif est que les individus
puissent se rendre en voiture être
testés sur place sans avoir besoin de
quitter la voiture je sais être père
single qui nous aide à développer un
site internet
cela sera très rapide contrairement au
site par le passé afin de vérifier s'il
y a raison d'être est de tester et où
aller se faire tester
nous avons beaucoup c'est possible nous
n'avons pas parlé du monde mais nous
nous nous occupons de notre pays en tout
premier lieu de plusieurs centaines de
personnes qui travaillent là dessus
notre objectif est dans le pacte
d'endiguer la propagation du virus
ils voient pas que tout le monde prenne
ce test ce n'est pas nécessaire
et la situation va passer et cela ne va
que renforcer ce avons appris beaucoup
de choses je souhaite on a cédé probable
je voudrais qu'elle vienne à lestrade
qui a prononcé quelques mots une
personne très respecté j'ai appris à
très bien la connaître au cours des six
derniers jours nous avons reconstruit
constitution très bien quasiment
obsolète
en tout cas obsolète vis-à-vis de ce
genre d'épidémie d'octobre s'il vous
plaît merci monsieur le président c'est
un plaisir nos relations pour
l'allocution de donald trump ce soir sur
le court au damier russe le président
américain qui a donc décrété
l'état d'urgence mesure est
exceptionnelle pour redonner en quelque
sorte la main à l'état afin de tenter de
résoudre cette propagation de
coronavirus sur le sol américain et pour
en parler nous sommes avec gabriel
galice président de l'institut de la
recherche pour la paix bonsoir gabriel
galice merci d'être avec nous sur rt
france vous avez suivi l'allocution du
président américain il dit j'avais
raison finalement la halle oms me donne
raison aujourd'hui c'est bien l'europe
l'épicentre de cette épidémie on se
souvient que le président américain
avait interdit aux européens de mettre
le pied sur le sol américain dans les 30
jours oui bonsoir
donald trump est assez facilement compte
ang lee je crois qu'il ya quand même des
réserves à émettre d'abord cette crise
nous montre une chose c'est que les
frontières existent contrairement à ce
que prétend dans un certain nombre de
personnes
les frontières existent la question est
quel usage en faisons-nous est à cet
égard je crois que il y a une grande
diversité dans la pratique des états que
les états unis ont une propension à
notamment avec donald 30 mais il n'est
pas le seul à pointer les
responsabilités des autres hier c'était
là la responsabilité des européens
aujourd'hui c'est aussi les chinois
plusieurs fois il à dire on a tenu la
chine à distance or la situation aux
états unis est loin d'être simple
d'abord il ya beaucoup de cas notamment
dans l'ohio
deuxièmement et ce sont les états qu'une
compétence en matière de santé non pas
l'état fédéral troisièmement il n'y a
pas d'assurance maladie universel dont
toutes les mesures qui ont été indiquées
à supposer qu'elles soient mises en
oeuvre vont se heurter à une difficulté
ça va être de payer tous ces soins de
maladie de médecins de médicaments
donc moi je suis quand même assez
inquiet
pour les états unis comme pour les
autres pays je crois qu'ils
n'échapperont pas de sérieuses
difficultés alors donald trump a annoncé
50 milliards de dollars qui seront
débloquées justement pour venir en aide
à ces à ces américains
finalement on sent que le président
américain tâtonne tout comme les
européens à ce sujet il dit on pourra
faire des tests mais pas deux mais tout
le monde ne sera pas concerné donc on
s'engage une certaine incertitude en
tout cas dans ce que dit le président
américain sur la propagation de ce virus
oui il est surpris comme tout le monde
en faisant un peu d'humour je dirais que
je pourrais conseiller au président des
états unis de se tourner vers cuba parce
que cuba qui fait l'objet d'un embargo
des états unis depuis très longtemps est
un de ceux qui a mis un accès aux points
donc c'est peut-être pas la peine de
réinventer le fil à couper le beurre
pour le président des états unis
mais tout le monde est surpris mais
effectivement je crois qu'il faut faire
preuve d'une solidarité internationale
qu'il faut coopérer dans votre reportage
antérieures on a vu la situation
dramatique en iran il faut quand même
dire que une des causes de la crise de
l'ampleur de la crise sanitaire en iran
c'est le fait qu'il y à un embargo
imposé par les etats-unis sur les
produits de santé et que c'est une cause
qui devrait être levé pas simplement par
les états unis mais l'ensemble des
partenaires mme les etats-unis font
pression sur les autres pays pour qu'ils
aient pas de relations avec l'iran donc
il faut que tout le monde joue le jeu
que la solidarité internationale soit
ouverte à tous les pays parce que ce
sont des peuples qui soupe et non pas
des dirigeants politiques
autre question évidemment ce coronavirus
s'invite dans la campagne on a vu
notamment la primaire démocrate qui sera
reportée dans un des états américains
la gestion de cette crise finalement
c'est le nouvel enjeu pour donald trump
pour cette présidentielle
oui parce que il avait fait réussite
économique
un point fort que ne lui contestait même
pas ses adversaires
or il est clair que la crise sanitaire
de fait va entraîner un ralentissement
économique
et on peut pas à la fois se vanter de
tenir la chine à distance et puis faire
comme si elle n'était pas le pourvoyeur
des etats-unis en grande partie 1 malgré
les taxes qu'on a mis sur les produits
en provenance de chine
donc il va jouer gros ses adversaires
ont commencé à montrer les insuffisances
des des mesures d'accompagnement qui ont
déjà été mises en oeuvre par
l'administration trump on va voir la
suite
moi je ne veux pas préjuger mais
visiblement il y a beaucoup de
difficultés qui sont en train de
s'amonceler
merci beaucoup gabriel galice d'avoir
répondu à nos questions sur rt france et
c'est la fin de ce journal merci de
votre fidélité on se retrouve dans moins
de quinze minutes à présent pour un
prochain point sur la formation rester
avec nous
[Musique]
bienvenue dans la grande interview
aujourd'hui je reçois le vice-président
du parlement russe la célèbre douma
piotr tolstoï bonjour monsieur bonjour
merci d'être avec nous sur ce plateau
alors piotte tolstoï vous êtes aux
premières loges du réchauffement entre
la france et la russie
emmanuel macron a fait d'eux non